it's too bad she won't live but then
again who does so I've just gotten back
from seeing Blade Runner 20 49 and this
could end up being a really confused
review because I'll probably get into
spoilers later I'll give a heads up
before I get into that but this movie is
good it is very good but I'm not sure if
I actually like it I'm still trying to
figure that out and maybe it would be
better if I had just slept on it rather
than making a review video right away
but that this is what I'm doing so here
we go anyway so the movie as I said it
is good it didn't even you this is only
the second film of his that I've seen
but he's absolutely a solid director
knows what he's doing they got Roger
Deakins as the cinematographer so it
looks gorgeous all the performances are
very good the progression of the story
is good despite being almost three hours
it there are moments that feel a little
dragged out but no individual scene is
superfluous and there aren't any you
know plot threads that are filler and
dragging it down so it doesn't feel
weighed down in that sense and it is a a
pretty admirable and I think well
thought-out continuation and progression
of the world the Blade Runner all that
having been said I'm still not entirely
sure I like it and it's because of
reasons that I'm gonna have to get into
spoilers for so I'll just say it's a
good movie it deserves to be seen but I
have weird things I'm still trying to
sort out about it so I'm gonna start
getting into spoilers with this I'm not
gonna detail the plot so if you hear
first an opposite of that I'm not gonna
give it to you so part of why I'm not
entirely sure where I'll aim with this
film is that my love of the original and
I do love the original it's one of my
favorite films but it's that love is
very specific because that film does
something that I love but so few stories
especially in the medium of film ever do
this and that is
a huge world but a small story because
generally when you have a world as big
and as designed and as expansive and as
intricate as the world of Blade Runner
as a general rule filmmakers also scale
up the story so that the story feels
like it is big enough to justify the
world you've created for it the original
Blade Runner doesn't really do that the
original Blade Runner is a small story
about characters who within the confines
of that story don't really matter I mean
in some cases what they are matters and
like what they represent matters but
like as individuals in the big scheme of
things these people don't really matter
our lead character especially and
there's something I like about that just
as a as a field that it's not quite like
the average Joe view but it's like it's
it's the story of someone who's not a
mover and shaker in this world the story
of someone who's not reshaping the
destiny of the environment in which they
live I mean it's part of why my favorite
film in the Alien franchise is the first
one huge world massive implications
small story it's part of my love of the
first two Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy books and it's a vibe that is
very difficult to find and this movie
doesn't quite have it the story and this
one is bigger the implications are
bigger the direct hand that the
characters we're following have in
events is bigger not so big that it's
like totally lost the thread but
definitely bigger than before this story
matters to this world much more so than
the original and there's nothing
inherently wrong with that and I think
in many ways it was probably the smarter
way to go I mean what's the alternative
if you did a story scaled the same way
that the original film was then it's
really hard to not just have him feel
like a retread so I don't think this was
the correct decision
to make it's just that because that key
part of my personal love of that
original movie is something that kind of
had to go in order to do this story yeah
it means it's a bit harder for me to
connect with this story also has more or
less flat out villains I mean we don't
know entirely what their deal is but the
way Jared Leto and the character of love
are introduced that they are very much
the villains of this story much more so
than anybody in the original Blade
Runner was and there's something about
Jared Leto's character specifically it
sounds bad I don't think it's the
performance I think it's the way the
characters written and there's just
something about him
coming out and spouting the
pseudo-religious I am a God kind of
thing that isn't quite working for me
because he's obviously sort of our
substitute Tyrell you know different
character very much in terms of his
approach but to make the comparison
anyway because it's valid Tyrell in the
first movie he seemed to understand his
own boundaries and he he seemed human he
didn't seem like a megalomaniac which is
how jared leto comes across and the
character of love I kind of went back
and forth on initially I liked her and
the actress plays are very well but she
got pushed further and further into
outright villainy by the end yet then
again at the very end there's some
moments they kind of bring her back and
that's another thing this will be
actually lost me through most of the
second act and then cut me back in the
third act the reason it lost me in the
second act is well first of all there's
the whole thing with a child having been
born from a replicant mother and I get
that that's a big deal and I'm okay with
that I'm less okay with that replicant
being Rachel and I'm I think I'm kind of
not okay with the father being Deckard
because again it's a retroactive Lee
makes them important in this world and
that that feels
feels masturbatory it feels like Oh
remember those characters from the first
movie
look at how important they are it's like
but they weren't that important in the
first movie anyway I've talked about
that already but the so the whole the
the inherent idea that a replicant has
had a child and the implications of that
being massive but I'm actually totally
okay with because the originals sort of
skirted on the very fringe of some big
ideas as well this one's a little bit
more front and center but it's got that
whole second act where it is really
heavy handedly implied that it is Jared
Leto oh and actually I'll pause right
there I really like the face that was in
scene one that he is a replicant and he
knows he is that was just a really good
way to deal with that right off the bat
with his character and tangent to the
tangent I love that they managed to
include Deckard and not definitively
answer the ambiguity of whether or not
Deckard is a replicant I knew that denis
villeneuve was in tempting to do that I
had no idea how he could include Deckard
and pull that off he did somehow props
to that but so there's that whole
segment where Jared Leto's character
believes that he is the child you know
that had that everyone's actor and
everyone wants to wants to figure out
what happened to and I didn't I didn't
like that entire segment there I kind of
want to watch the movie again to see now
that I know that that is in fact not the
case whether that'll play better for me
and I feel like I should have guessed
that earlier on because it didn't seem
so heavy-handed with it but that whole
segment I was like are we really doing
son of Deckard and it still could've
blown it even when it revealed that was
not the case cuz it could have if it had
been like trying to be too clever about
it could have come across as we fooled
you as like well no you were doing
something stupid and you stopped doing
that stupid thing I appreciate that but
I'm not gonna give you points for it but
it really did pull it off just well
enough basically by focusing on the gut
punch of
that too the character of Kay Ryan
Gosling's character himself and that was
a really good way to hinge that so that
rather than feel it like a twist on the
audience it was just a gut punch for
that character and that was a good way
so the movie lost me pretty much through
most of that second acting got me back
at that point and then pretty much had
me through the remainder of it I need to
see this thing at least one more time to
really firm up my opinion of it because
now that I have a better sense of you
know sort of the lull period and I know
it's not doing the thing that I was
afraid it was doing when I was actually
watching it that maybe that whole
segmental played better for me I don't
know now but yeah this is a really well
made movie and I wish it was doing
better at the box office I really do
and I'm I am glad that I saw it even
though I'm still not entirely sure I
like I know I like the original better
but honestly that was never a question
in my mind there was net eye there was
never a possibility I was gonna like
this better having talked it out I'm
leaning more towards liking it then I
had been but there are some reservations
it's based in the case of this movie
either just barely hits the yeah I like
it thing or it just barely missed it and
I'm not entirely sure which is it's
gonna be a really close call but I still
if you're still watching if you stuck
through the spoilers and haven't watched
yet that's a shame cuz I would really
encourage anyone to go and watch this
even if you haven't seen the original
because honestly you don't need to have
had seen the original in order to have
this make sense and have it work so it's
a piece of smart high concept big-budget
sci-fi it deserves to be seen I would
like to see it do well so that we can
get more movies like this not in terms
of reviving old franchises we're getting
too much of that but just in terms of
allowing this biggest scale and this big
a canvas for ideas like this what are
your thoughts about Blade Runner 2049
wherever whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter a
council of geeks give a listen to the
council week's podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also
half of the punch like a girl podcast
now available on the fire and water
podcast network fire and Water podcast
comm and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]